Welcome back everyone this will be my full black
panther 2 wakanda forever trailer video from comic
con kevin feige woke up and chose violence
today because he announced so many things we
have two avengers movies in the same year in 2025
they confirmed avengers 5 kang dynasty which is
basically like kang war in avengers 6 is secret
wars don't worry i will do videos for all that
stuff too be sure to subscribe to get everything
it is going to be crazy seriously shut up and take
my money that is just the beginning like there are
so many things so much footage that they released
at comic con but the black panther 2 movie is all
about introducing namor's character riri williams
is iron heart explaining who the next black
panther is going to be who's going to rule wakanda
and what's going on with t'challa's son that's
right you actually see the birth of t'challa's
son in the trailer during the movie nakia reveals
that she had a secret love child with t'challa
before they got married the music track that plays
over it is everything's gonna be all right because
there's this big lamentation because you're
talking about the death of t'challa like they open
the trailer with this funeral procession that's
why all these people are dressed in white here
because it's meant to be a twist on the idea that
you wear black during morning but you see some of
the characters wearing black and mourning later in
the trailer too being all sad that's why t'challa
and shuri's mother is so pissed off during the
trailer she says she's lost her entire family
probably the other biggest reveal is the new
black panther at the end of the trailer you
see all the golden highlights on the new black
panther suit the new black panther is supposed to
be a version of shuri there's a scene where you
see all the fire around her in that ceremonial
chamber with all the water she's supposed to use
her technology to create an artificial version of
the heart-shaped herb and there's going to be some
twists with that where she gets some advice from
the ancestral plane and they are supposed to bring
back a version of killmonger through the ancestral
plane he's supposed to help her become the next
black panther instead of t'challa themselves
because they're not going to do a carrie fisher
situation where they have an artificial version
of t'challa on screen just thinking that would
probably upset everyone too much and obviously
there's a bunch of footage of atlantis here with
versions of namor like a child version of namor
you see an older version of him walking up to the
shores of atlantis with a bunch of blue atlanteans
around the screen you see namor and a bunch
of atlanteans using the giant whales as attack
vessels underwater this scene of the character
banging out the heart in the iron is obviously
meant to be a version of riri williams ironheart
creating a version of her mark 1 suit it's meant
to be a reference to the original iron man movie
in the cave scene with him making his mark 1 suit
like she has her own version of a mark 1 just
like he did all the footage of the characters
on the ship in the ocean using those regular
looking suits is them trying to find a version
of vibranium underwater that's what causes them to
disturb namor and the atlanteans and threaten them
supposedly the connection here is that doctor doom
is going to be behind this team that's looking for
more vibranium like doctor doom has a version
of doom war in the movie where he's looking for
vibranium and sort of pulling the strings from
behind the scenes so namor and the atlanteans
aren't really meant to be villains obviously none
of the wakandans are meant to be villains either
or any of the black panther characters it's all
the faults of doctor doom's character and they
also announced the new fantastic four movie too
that's gonna be the beginning of marvel phase six
but it's not coming out to the beginning of 2024
this is like the entire marvel phase six schedule
even though they have all these mystery dates
that they haven't announced yet they'll fill those
blanks in at d23 later this year it's just the
big deal that they announced at the end of marvel
phase six is gonna be the two avengers movies back
to back seriously can you believe that they're
gonna have two avengers movies in the same year
like shut up and take my money it's gonna be crazy
but now you can see why they're introducing doctor
doom stuff during black panther too even if we
don't see him on screen they'll probably have some
moment during the film maybe like a tag scene or
post-credit scene at the end that will imply that
he was responsible for a lot of what happened
during the movie you can obviously see a lot of
scenes early in the trailer is then just trying
to deal with the death of t'challa and not really
sure what to do next all just being really upset
about it i believe the way that they're explaining
his death during the movie is that he'll have some
sort of sickness and he'll pass away before
the events of the beginning of the movie
so it won't be like namor winds up killing him but
like later in the trailer you see them literally
attacking wakanda like it's a version of the
comic book story where namor and atlantis attacks
wakanda and floods it basically that seems like
it's happening much later in the film though after
what happens with riri williams technology in this
team that doctor doom is funding uses it to find
atlantis looking for vibranium and then they go
after riri williams who's in mit you see a lot
of these fight scenes in and around the cambridge
area it sounds like shirty and okoye in the door
milage wind up trying to protect riri williams
and that's what puts them at odds with namor and
why namor wants to attack wakanda like the friend
of my enemy is now also my enemy as well even if
wakanda didn't do anything in the first place all
the writing in wakandan here in this scene on the
pillars is actually meant to be a real-life
translation to a tribute to chadwick boseman
like yes it's written in wakandan but it's really
meant to be a subtle tribute to chadwick boseman
himself most of all these water scenes during
the trailer obviously meant to imply the debut of
atlantis and namor the atlanteans during the movie
they're supposed to have a really big water-based
battle during the film obviously you would try
to do that because of the atlanteans atlantis
this scene of namor underwater with him with a
giant headdress is actually meant to be in his
god-tier form like he's meant to form a contract
with the god of their people the same way that
black panther has a contract with boss the panther
goddess who he saw during thor love and thunder
giving him all his special abilities his powers
won't be exactly like black panther's powers that
he gets from boston the heart-shaped herb but
it'd be similar situation like a major upgrade
to his character giving him all of his comic book
powers parts of his costume also are inspired by
the comic book costume like he has the wings on
his feet when he has his god tier avatar form
the way they're playing this conflict up
though between the three different sides
is meant to be very captain america civil war kind
of situation i've talked about in previous videos
where you have two sides namor atlantis and
wakanda fighting each other but neither one of
them is totally at fault it's always like a third
party that's responsible for everything that third
party is probably going to wind up being doctor
doom this team invading here with the soldier
forcing the person to read what looks like these
runes here seems like the team working for doctor
doom like i said i'm assuming this scene with
shuri with the fire all around her is her using
the artificial heart shaped herb and her entering
a version of the ancestral plane like some big
ceremony where she finds out what's really going
on and how she's going to become the next black
panther with a big killmonger twist like wait a
minute i was looking for my brother not for you
you get some new shots of her lab obviously she's
going to create her own version of a black panther
suit for herself i think the idea that killmonger
winds up helping her become the next black panther
is why some of her costume is inspired by
killmonger's golden jaguar looking black panther
costume like that was kind of the joke when
t'challa was choosing between new black panthers
he said no no this gold one is way too showy
for me but sure he is all about that showiness
all these flashbacks of a young version of namor
with atlanteans here just seem like his tragic
backstory like i'll explain why he hates people
who live above water so much the way they're
explaining atlantis during the movie is that
it's been hidden from the world the same way
that wakanda hid itself from the world this whole
time is this mysterious new technology that rir
williams creates that's being co-opted by doctor
doom that winds up outing them to the rest of the
world threatening to reveal all their secrets
to everyone because of the entire world we're
able to enter wakanda for instance everybody wants
what they have all their advanced technology now
there's the same threat with everyone descending
on atlantis trying to steal what it has and that's
the real reason why namor is so pissed off he's
worried about that worried about his people
there's a bunch of new scenes of umbacu's palace
here it sounds like he's actually going to be the
new ruler of wakanda like shuri isn't going to
take the throne she'll just become the new black
panther innumbaku is going to become the new ruler
of their people separately like they're going to
separate the two jobs they did tease the movie was
going to become way more international too like
you see raimond addressing the united nations
sort of the same way that t'challa did at the
end of the first black panther movie most of the
atlanteans throughout the trailer looked pretty
close to their comic book counterparts obviously
trying to translate this to live action the reason
why namor doesn't look blue like the others is
because he's only half atlantean like his mother
was atlantean his father was a normal human they
also call him the first mutant so i think they're
going to explain that he's a mutant during the
movie because there's all these mutants debuting
now like miss marvel is now a mutant in the mcu
we'll probably meet more mutants throughout marvel
phase five obviously we have new scenes with
everett ross he's a big part of the film they
also confirmed everett ross is coming back during
secret invasion too so there'll be a lot more of
him during marvel phase four marvel phase five the
other big news too is that black panther two will
be the end of marvel phase four the beginning of
marvel phase five will actually start with ant-man
three quantum media the end of marvel phase 5
will be the thunderbolts movie right after captain
america 4. marvel phase 6 will begin with the
new fantastic four movie and end with the second
avengers 6 movie during 2025 remember two avengers
movies that year with the secret wars film they're
basically calling all of marvel phase four phase
five and phase six the multiverse saga like the
next big saga after the infinity saga which
was marvel phase one phase two and phase three
i'll do a separate avengers video about
all the announcements with secret wars
all the kang stuff everything that's going
on during marvel phase five marvel phase six
because like they just confirmed that there's
gonna be 18 episodes of daredevil season one
we also just got a bunch of other trailer footage
too we learned all about guardians of the galaxy
three we got new she-hulk footage it'll take me
a long time to get through all this stuff there's
just so much cool stuff to talk about i think
the idea with the iron heart character too is
that at the end of the film because there's this
big connection with shuri with okoye they help
protect her during the film they're going to have
a deeper relationship going forward in the future
and they'll help her create her next iron man mark
iii style suit like her comic book accurate iron
heart suit will be a vibranium iron man looking
suit michaela cooper is another new character
it seems like she's going to be one of the new
dora milaje characters this is more of namor
teasing his past i think they're tying them more
to the mayans in their history in the real world
like they're saying that the atlanteans are
descendants of ancient mayans that split off
of their culture this scene here just seems like
namor in atlantis with a giant shark skulls here
addressing the rest of his people as they get
ready to declare war on the wakandans this is
probably more of the water-based battle that they
have with adorama lager versus the atlanteans
and then obviously we have shuri in her new black
panther costume fighting a version of namor this
is namor in the background if you couldn't tell
everybody let me know what you think about her
new black panther suit clearly it's meant to
be a very feminine looking figure so i think it
does confirm that shuri is going to become the
next black panther like she did in the comics
if you look at the way they reveal the title
too like there's gold highlights on the silver
wakanda forever title i think that's meant to
be a reference to her new costume having all
the gold highlights on it the real question here
is what they're gonna do with t'challa's mystery
son like obviously it sounds like he's gonna be
born at some point during the film or they'll
tease him during the film in some way i think the
idea is that when he comes of age he'll eventually
become the next king of wakanda and the next black
panther just like t'challa but no idea how long
they're gonna tease that out just because of the
way they're plotting out the next avengers movies
avengers 5 avengers 6 it might be like three or
four years before you actually see a much older
version of that character but if they are gonna
do young avengers in the future at some point they
could bring a version of him back as a teenager
and he'd be a version of black panther during that
but everybody post all your doctor doom theories
in the comments below because obviously we have
all this fantastic four and all this kang secret
war stuff happening in the future there's just
so many directions that they could go with this
there's so much cool stuff to freak out about
what'll happen is i'll do a she-hulk trailer
video next that'll post early sunday morning
and after that i'll just double up my videos every
day until i get through all the big announcements
and all the big trailers that they just released
if you have any big marvel questions about the
announcements they made about their comic con
panel or any easter eggs that you spotted in
this trailer that i didn't talk about in the video
just write them below in the comments and i'll be
sure to add that stuff to my next couple of videos
everyone click here for my brand new black panther
2 doctor doom video and click here for my brand
new she-hulk trailer video i'll update the link
as soon as i post that thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe in wakanda forever!